in this video we shall compare the new
creatures and new titans that were seen
in godzilla vs kong we will compare the
final designs of these monsters with the
concept are the original ones that were
totally different we will see what they
were planned to look like versus how
they turned out a shout out to
iamag.co this website for the collection
of these amazing artwork by artists such
as xander smith matt millett and kyle
brown
now let's compare these side by side and
decide for ourselves which ones are
better
number one arachno claw in terms of
general appearance the arachna claws
resemble giant spiders albeit heavily
armoured with small faces and crap like
pincers their carapaces resemble rocks
most likely evolve as a form of
camouflage they were around 10 to 15
feet tall and dwell in rocky landscapes
only coming out to the surface when the
land is disturbed by large creatures in
the concept are the design of these
creatures didn't change much which means
that their original look was appreciated
and accepted into the movie
they had hard care bases and had six
legs with two gigantic pincers that are
shielded with a rocky exoskeleton
in some artwork the carapace has a heavy
gravestone covering which would provide
it with extra camouflage and armor
these creatures were supposedly bigger
around 25 to 30 feet in height double
the final versions
number two the hellholes the hellhounds
are aggressive predatory creatures that
inhabit hollow earth like bats they
prefer to inhabit caves in dark caverns
and spend their time hanging upside down
from the ceiling hellholes resemble
giant bats with vulture-like heads
talons literary wings and armored backs
covered with thin strands of hair like
feathers and they were around 9-10 feet
tall
in the concept art these flying
creatures were a lot bigger around 50 to
60 feet tall and with a wingspan of
maybe 200 feet across they have blue
eyes and were more robust with wings
that grew out of the hands and their
five fingers were present and still
unchanged into parts of their wings
their backs were more armoured and the
talons and claws were as big as a single
aircraft in our opinion a flock of these
would have given karma run for his money
in the throne room
number three the hollow earth lizard
hollow earth lizards are large
reptilians being grayish black in
coloration with rows of spikes and
osteoderms covering their back
likely as a means of defense from other
predators within the hollow earth their
heads are stubby and jaws filled with
sharp teeth
their eyes are almost forward facing
similar to any modern predatory species
their eyes also possess a bony ridge
above their eye socket similar to
crocodilians in the concept designs of
this hollow earth lizard it showed that
they were more menacing in looks
something which would have been more
than just form of a new world but actual
monsters that would scare the crap out
of you it is seen to have a face similar
to anguirus with a very spiky body with
sharp osteodynes it is also slimmer and
looks to be fast and agile its tail is
also spiked and
all the way to the end of the day where
we can see a club form as a means of
attack or of defense
number four the war bats
warbats are large reptilian serpentine
creatures being grazed in coloration and
equipped with two red membranous wings
running down from the top half of its
body supported by long spines which are
extensions of the rib cage their torso
is similar to that of a snake being long
and slender and warbats resemble a cobra
the bottom half of the torso has ventral
scales further adding to the resemblance
of a snake warbat blood is green light
in coloration and also they could fly
there are a couple of warbat concept
designs one which has a slimmer look to
the monster with a tail that seemingly
has some sort of electrical powers the
warbat here has its wings grown from the
body and attached to its two six
prehensile limbs that look like spines
coming out from the ribcage all from the
sides of the body the other design
however resembles the final one but is
more robust and heavier looking and
actually has a split jaw with a tail
that has two spikes that are or maybe
outgrowths which can be used as stings
and number five mecha godzilla this
mecca looks like it has a skeletal
appearance albeit that of godzilla's it
sports a series of short metal plates
resembling that of the dorsal plates of
the g-man running from the back of its
neck all the way down to the tip of its
tail its four limbs are considerably
longer and bulkier
with four zygote dactyl gloves which it
can use to grab things or punch godzilla
with them its feet resembles that of
ghidoras and also a little bit
having the frame of godzillas
its tail has a drill mounted on its tip
which could be a dangerous weapon
like the warba there were two designs
for mecha godzilla the concept designs
that is one of which shows a very basic
robotic design without spikes or dorsal
plates or anything of that sort
resembling the g-man except for the
dinosaur posture and the big tail
the second art shows the same one birth
being covered in armor and the thicker
skeletal looking exoskeleton but was
still totally different from the final
version this one looked like an early
dinosaur model but covered in armor and
fragile metal parts it would have been
sluggish and non-threatening to even
look at so that's why it wasn't accepted
into the final form
and so with that we come to the end of
the video on the comparison of the
concept and final designs of the
creatures of godzilla vs comb subscribe
like and smash the bell button for
regular updates on new monster content
right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam